المعارك ضاريه تخوضها القوات الروسيه
للسيطره على مدينه الاستراتيجيه حيث يزداد
الوضع صعوبه على القوات الاوكرانيه كما
تشير اخر المعلومات الميدانيه
الجيش الاوكراني اوضح ان الوضع متوتر جدا
حول باخمت وقال قائد القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه الكسندر سيريسكي ان الروس
ارسلوا الوحدات الاكثر جهوزيه في مجموعه
فاغنر التي تحاول اختراق الدفاعات
الاوكرانيه ومحاصره المدينه
وقد تمكنت القوات الروسيه من قطع ثلاثه من
الطرق الاربعه التي تسمح للاوكرانيين
بادخال الامدادات الى باخموت ولم يتبقى
متاحا سوى الطريق المؤدي الى الغرب باتجاه
والذي يحاول الروس التقدم نحوه من الجنوب
هذا وتعد المعارك في بخمت بمنطقه الدوناتس
شرق البلاد الاعنف منذ بدء العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه حيث تتعرض خطوط الدفاع
الاوكرانيه لقصف عنيف بسبب الهجوم الروسي
المتجدد وعلى الرغم من خضوع جزء من
المنطقه لسيطره الروس وحلفائهم
الانفصاليين الا ان بخمت ما زالت تحت
سيطره الاوكرانيين حتى الان هذا بالاضافه
الى مقاطعه خركيب الواقعه شمال شرق
اوكرانيا
ومدينتيزيوم واليمن التي استعادتهما
القوات الاوكرانيه من قبضه الجيش الروسي
اما المناطق الخاضعه للسيطره العسكريه
الروسيه في اقليم الدومبس فتشمل دونتسك
ومع محاوله القوات الروسيه السيطره على
تلك المدينه الاستراتيجيه منذ اكثر من سته
اشهر يقول الرئيس الاوكراني ان القوات
الروسيه تدمر كل ما يمكن لحمايه مواقعها
بشكل مستمر
نقيب اوكراني تحدث عن وجود نقص في الذخيره
وخاصه قذائف المدفعيه وبعد ناقلات الجند
المدرعه لتحريك القوات
ورغم نقص الموارد ما زالت القوات
الاوكرانيه تسيطر على المدينه لان انسحاب
المدافعين عن باخموت سيؤدي الى تمهيد
الطريق لروسيا للدفع باتجاه مدن اكبر في
شرق اوكرانيا مثل كراماتورسك
[موسيقى]
ليت
الى دونيسكا حيث مراسل العربيه يتابع
انكتب الاوضاع في بخموت رائد اهلا وسهلا
بك
ثم باخموت ولا شيء غير باقمه الان اخر
المعلومات البدنيه رائد وهل باتت المدينه
تعتبر في حكم الساقطه عسكريا بالنسبه الى
الروس ام لا يمكن قول ذلك
مساء الخير
عزيزي بالفعل معارك مستعره هنا في المحور
الشرقي من
من اوكرانيا وفي المحور الشمالي من مقاطعه
دانيتس بالفعل مدينه باخموت مستعره بالفعل
بالمعارك ما بين الطرفين ربما ان نقصد
ذخيره كما اسلفت عزيزي هو يعني السبب الذي
يجعل القوات الروسيه تتقدم نقصد ذخيره عند
الجانب الاوكراني بالفعل قوات فارنار دخلت
من اطراف المدينه الشماليه يوم امس في حي
احد الاحياء
ستوبينكا بالفعل دخلت واظهرت فيديوهات
للقوات الروسيه وهي يعني
تتحرك وتتقدم في شوارع داخل مدينه باخمد
كما ان المحور الجنوبي تقدمت منه القوات
ايضا ودخلت الى الاحياء السكنيه المحور
الشرقي يشهد معارك ايضا محتدمه وضاريه ما
بين جانبين في مناطق المصانع والمعامل
المحور الغربي هو الوحيد الذي بقي يعني
منفتحا امام الجيش الاوكراني اما للانسحاب
واما للامدادات العسكريه ان كان بالجنود
او بالذخيره تحاول قوات فاجنر التقدم طالب
يعني توسيع الطوق من الناحيه الشماليه الى
الشماليه الغربيه هناك بلده تدعى بغداد
الروسيه على بلده ياجد نيا وبيريخوف كعده
بلدات في المحور الشمالي قبل ان تدخل الى
بلده ستوبكي وتتقدم لتوسيع الطوق اذا وصلت
الى بلده بقدانه كهذا يعني بان الطوق يكون
تقريبا قد اكتمل الا من ممرات يعني ضيقه
جدا هناك كما اسلفت هو الوحيد الذي يوصل
الامدادات العسكريه ربما في الفتره
الاخيره والقوات الروسيه قوات فاجنر
تحديدا تبعد كيلو متر واحد عن هذا الطريق
المشاهدين دائما دائما يسالون ما يعني هل
يمكن الفصل بين قوات فاجنير والقوات
الروسيه ام لا يعني في هذه المعركه لا
يمكن الفصل بينهما وفي حال سقطت ما الذي
يعنيه ذلك بالنسبه الى القوات الروسيه ما
هو الهدف التالي او المدينه التاليه
البوابه الرئيسيه هذا من جانب لكن من جانب
اخر الفرق ما بين قوات باقنر والجيش
الروسي
الجيش الروسي هو جيش منظم تابع للدفاع
الروسيه قوات فاجنر هي مؤسسه شركه خاصه
وتعمل يعني
بدعم ربما
بالذخيره لكن ليس بالقياده من قبل الدفاع
الروسيه وهذا ما يجعل التباين والتناقض
دائما ما بين
القدر منذ مراسل العربيه رائد لاغبر شكرا
جزيلا لك رائد على كل هذه المتابعه
الى كيف الان موفد العربيه احمد بجاتو
يوافينا باخر التطورات احمد اهلا وسهلا بك
قبل ان اسالك عن وجهه النظر الاوكرانيه
حول تطورات المعركه في بخموت العواج منذ
قليل تحدثت عن انفجارات قويه في كييف اخر
المعلومات
نعم ليس صحيحا طالب يعني ما حدث هو حريق
وانفجار الاسطوانات الغاز ليس شيئا كبيرا
للغايه هكذا تقول الاداره المحليه اذا ليس
هناك انفجار كبير كما تحدثت بعض وصايا
الانباء لكن اذا تحدثنا عن بخمت وهي
المعركه الاهم والاكثر شراسه الان والتي
يتحدث عنها الجميع ليس فقط وسائل الاعلام
والقاده السياسيين وانما ايضا الروس
واوكرانيا المواطنين يعني
قوات البريه يتحدث وايضا نائبه وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني عن ان الوضع صعب للغايه
بالنسبه للقوات الاوكرانيه في بخمه الان
نظرا للشراسه الهجوميه التي تقوم بها قوات
فاجنر والتي يعني يعني تقدم النخبه من
قواتها لمهاجمه مواقع القوات الاوكرانيه
وايضا مدعومه بالطيران الحربي والمسيرات
وكذلك المدفعيه المدينه باتت شبه مدمره
بالكامل
المدينه التي كان بها اكثر من 7 من
المواطنين يوجد فيها الان اقل من الفين
مواطن الصور توضح بجلاء حجم الضمائر الذي
طال هذه المدينه القوات الاوكرانيه
والقياده هنا تتحدث عن ان من 600 الى
من عسكري من قوات فاجنر يقتلون يوميا في
الهجمات التي تقودها او تقودها القوات
الروسيه مع قوات الاوكرانيه
لكن هذا لم يمنحهم التقدم هم يريدون
السيطره على المدينه باي طريق باي طريق
كان وحتى اتحدث بانهم يتبعون اسلوب
الاستنزاف التام والتدمير الكامل للمدينه
يريدون السيطره عليها باي شكل كان حتى
يصلوا الى سفيان وكذلك ايضا كروموسك
اللتان يعني تسلم ايضا من القصف احيانا من
قبل المدفعيه والصواريخ الروسيه طيب نعم
ايضا هناك حديث عن انه مع اقتراب الربيع
سيكون من الصعبه على قوات للتقدم لان
الارض ستصبح طونيه وموحله سيكون ما صعبه
على الاليات العسكريه الروسيه التقدم ما
زالت المطالب احمد انت انت وافق متابعتك
انت وفق متابعتك سواء لتصريحات المسؤولين
للاكراد تحديدا الاوكرانيين تحديدا
العسكريين وحتى وسائل الاعلام الاوكرانيه
في كييف وفي غير كياب هل
تتعامل السلطات الاوكرانيه مع معركه بخموت
على انها معركه خاسره
هم لا يتحدثون عنها انها معركه خاسره لكن
يقولون انهم يتراجعون يتراجعون ويصفون هذا
التراجع بالتراجع الظرفي والتكتيكي لا
يقولون انهم سيخسرون المدينه لكن هم
يقولون انهم يتراجعون هذا ما يقوله القاده
الاوكراني وبالفعل هم يقولون الوضع صعب
للغايه على القوات الموجوده هناك ولذلك
يدفعون شيئا فشيئا به قوات اخرى لدعم
القوات الموجوده في هذه المدينه من ناحيه
الغربيه بالطبع لان يعني هناك محاوله
تطويق من الجانب الشمالي والجنوبي والشرقي
من جانب قوات فاجنر للقوات المتواجده هناك
تراجع بالفعل هذا لا يمكنه احد في بخموت
لكن هم لا يريدون هذا التراجع ان يكون
سريعا لانه اذا كان هذا التراجع سريعا
ستسقط في النهايه في ايدي القوات الروسيه
ومن ثم سيكون الانطلاق الى مناطق اكثر
اخرى اكثر اهميه اهميه بخمه ليست كبيره هي
فقط اكتسبت اهميتها من كونها باتت عصيه
على الروس فتره طويله لذلك باتت يعني ملء
السنه والبصر الان لكنها ليست بالاهميه
التي يتم الحديث عنها لكن يعني مساله
كرامه الان بالنسبه لروسي هذه المدينه
الصغيره التي لم يستطيعوا السيطره عليها
لمده اشهر مفرد العربيه احمد نجاتو دائما
احمد شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المتابعه